[Musica]
come fatto bene da tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video io sono fa vj e
per questo video ho voluto un po
cambiare la mia intro per rendere il
tutto più originale spero sia di vostro
divertimento ben tarati su un altro
episodio di unboxing pari j
e prima di introdurre il tutto direi di
far uscire il pacco in questi 8 come
sapete tutti dentro le varie scatole io
non so che cosa c'è ogni in ogni puntata
ci sono delle sorprese
io passerei sisters accordo alle scatola
mento però per farlo mi serve l'attrezzo
del mestiere
parigi non è vero non mi sono fatto così
male
largo allora non so bene cosa aspettarmi
volta visto che la fantasia degli autori
non al limite ma che abbiamo sempre i
nostri amici scoppiettii oggi si vede
che problemi cioè l'energia mai nel
pacco di oggi abbiamo che cos'è questa
roba
abbiamo delle cose da quella più grossa
che vedo che c'è davanti non abbiamo il
tool a lake golf che penso sia allora
per ligustico perché sarebbe molto utile
perché noi non situazioni per i nostri
video sul trono quasi tutti quei pochi
te che ci vengono adesso verranno
cancellate completamente perché in
questo qua mi distraggo ha concesso
quindi approccio il secondo oggetto di
oggi è una cosa un po la pro visto che
questa qua non richiede posizioni strane
per essere utilizzata
[Musica]
non funziona è la clessidra rotta e una
crescita al contrario perché il tempo è
relativo nelle nostre vite
qualche santo a fare l'estate vabbè la
metto da parte magari vi servirà in
futuro ottima comunque c'è cioè fatte
dalla classica di cinesi però è una
bella idea quindi ma next capire come
avete trovato cosenza iscritto preside
al contrario permettere in questo patto
non lo sappiamo a sono spine di logica
cicero nessuno ora per capire solo che
sono spiriti di logica figura che a
farle
siccome è cominciato subito con i
videogame ti ho portato un rompicapo da
farlo in maniera bambina sta facendo da
bambina questo non è sfida per farvi j
devo riuscire a far uscire il pezzo in
mezzo come potete vedere non non è
proprio semplice perché bisogna
effettuare una rotazione attorno all
impotenza e faceva fare questa roba da
piccola spiegami perchè non sei ad
harvard perché si può registrare video
con fa vj piedi a me non ci sono le
soluzioni
allora la logica diventa subito molto
più interessante magari l'avessi avuta
durante le verifiche dei no
gn testimoni
questo è l'anello che darò mia moglie
deve avere un dito striminzito non me ne
frega niente la cercherò apposta ma
questa roba
la so fare abbiamo più la quella
successiva è un un oggetto che è sempre
stato un po nel cuore perché lo
conoscevo già per è sempre bello
ricordarlo prefazione che non lo tiriamo
fuori la perla allora qua abbiamo niente
questa è una bolla no dentro non c'è
niente aprire il pacchetto con molta
cautela di san giuseppe numero due
vivi il nulla attenzione non aprire
perché potrebbe contenere poi qualcosa
quindi lasciamo così senza intaccare la
sua essenza di nulla
questa roba la si compra a 8 euro perché
l'ho già comprata ne ho due
io penso che questo sia il regalo
migliore da fare ai vostri alex next
allora io sono uno che non sto toccando
ma non lo devo usare lo vedo mi piace 10
lo metto dietro
no no no no no allora questa
elettrostatica choc
ok il miglio verde questa roba qua
mettiamo sopra fuori ti odio personale
no non ci ho messo parecchio io odio
delle scariche elettrostatiche le odio e
se fossi un pokémon elettro sarebbe il
mio punto debole
io non posso usare
[Musica]
lui deve rispondere e quello dalla
scossa se dice la verità verità una
bugia per la mattina mi vuoi bene
realmente tantissimo
brava ragazza preferisci registrare
video per me o per gli eau topi per gli
addobbi in realtà ti fa malissimo e non
lo volesse di fare fare i bisogni di un
atto di pubblico per giocare mi aspetto
niente riprova per massa direi che
possiamo portare al prossimo pacco
ragazzi stavolta siamo sul kiwi fornelli
corona gonfiabile la pena perché
terribili tour italia io amo i miei
amici
vorrei proprio essere la regina perché
sto potere perché vive un sacco
la reggina che non fa nomi io vorrei
estrapolare questo potere della regina
di poter succedere a tutti
è una cosa veramente frega possono
scappare così come stituti next pacco
valsi bowles che in italiano vuol dire
palle rimbalzanti ma bisogna farle no no
non è vero
no il mio sogno del mondo dove già
allora clip de due parti insieme quindi
le due parti vanno inserite insieme
si ferma le due partite sempre tutte e
due metti i cristalli nel qua dentro in
diversi colori per creare list stripes
io faccio la mia palla convoglio ma devo
riempirlo a tutta immagino allo ragazzi
oggi vi insegno come si cucina questa
roba che state vedendo questo creando è
una pallina rimbalzante di quelle che
comprate di bonn nelle macchinette
comprovate da bambini quando io cucino i
miei alimenti hanno la stessa
consistenza ho capito è difficile è
difficile di noleggio fare queste cose
che il e controllo parte da bambino
inutili soldi nella macchinetta la
macchina si sganciava la pallina non è
così semplice come sembra
bene ci ho messo una vita a riempire
questa roba
ora dobbiamo solidificare la in teoria
quindi di istruzioni sono niente ho
preso dell'acqua che serve per
solidificare questa cosa mi lamento
dentro vado a prendere l'ultimo fa con
nella scatola nel mentre che questa roba
si solidifica vado ragazzi miei questa è
l'ultima cosa di oggi che il il bowling
di suore di fare strike con le scuole
facevo degli strike con le vecchie che
si è inventato sta roba c'è stato
veramente delle suore per fare strani ma
io voglio avere dell'istruzione perché
voglio vedere guarda la bibbia
cos'è e la bibbia del bowling di suore
che ha scritto sta roba
ho letto solo la parola c'è scritto
esorcista quindi va bene e troviamo non
so quanto possa essere difficile provare
il buio
il professore prima nel frattempo che
lanciamo la pallina tolgo qua perché
dovrebbe esserci solidificato il tutto è
la lascio a frugare li mortacci della
tua sorella e dell'altra e sorelle
guarda che è rimasta solo quella davanti
solo quella davanti ma cribbio ci ho
messo un'ora piazzar è un traguardo
molto buono non da dio come secondo me
non lo so se è venuto meno proviamo e
invece sto male non è vero che funziona
non ci credo non funzionano chiaramente
abbiamo fece un test ma da ragazzi visto
che questa è la prima coach e non sapete
disturbi dell'acqua quella con maud
haber uno schifo questa venuta veramente
bene siamo altresì finale quindi lei
possiamo venderle facciamo i soldini in
mezzo
quindi ragazzi incredibilmente siamo
riusciti a fare tutto in questo episodio
ci sono uscite le cose di logiche la
pallina
tutte cose per bambini però c'è il dalle
tavole scappare neanche quelle di solito
quindi ottimo quindi ragazzi spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto
la puntata di e box i file di oggi vice
qua lavorano me la tengo perché
giustamente mi spetta e siccome io ogni
volta che chiudo video ho bisogno del
telecomando ma mi dimentico sempre
prenderlo chiedo alla mia regia di
lanciarne uno piano grazie ai positivi e
quella che ha anche rilasciato dalle
scritte sono state mischiate vi
uccidiamo casinò fare questa cosa tempo
comunque non è da tutti a cagare in
mutande non so voi
[Musica]